a right-wing watchdog group that is a
watchdog group that that watches the
right wing
they've uncovered something quite
sinister related to uh ron desantis
so this is put up 10a okay so
this is the twitter account patriot
takes
and uh they tweeted out ron desantis's
family is wearing the exact same clothes
in both their christmas and new year
instagram posts
this is this is stunning
this is a stunning i i think there's
going to be a political pulitzer prize
for this
this is maybe the great
perhaps the greatest political scandal
certainly of the 21st century
that rhonda sanders's family they're
wearing the same clothing in what's
going on here exactly and you you click
on that tweet and you read all the
comments underneath it
and it's a bunch of people asking that
what's going on what's what's what is
what's happening what does this all mean
wearing the same clothing and two
different
well
i i just have a one theory here
if i if i could
it could be that there's something
really sinister happening i don't know
or it could be
that ron desantis got his family
together for a photo shoot
and i could guarantee it wasn't his idea
it was his wife's idea it's never the
man's idea so i should say ronda
sanders's wife got the family together
for a photo shoot
forced them all there
and then what what they did was they
took multiple photos
and now his social media team is putting
those photos up at various different
times
because what i can tell you from
experience again
is that um this is one of the reasons
why as a man it'll never be your
decision to take any kind of photo shoot
because it's it's not what i'll talk
about cost benefit analysis never worth
the cost
because first you got to get all those
kids in the nice clothing
and that's a whole
and available let them walk around the
house a little bit and they'll be fine
but with a boy you put them in nice
clothing and within five minutes
it's it looks like he was rolling around
in a barn
so you do all that you keep them clean
you you get them into an environment you
got the photographer there
and to actually get them to look at a
camera and smile
if you can if you can get them in that
the mood where they're actually going to
do that where you're going to take full
advantage and take as many pictures as
you can
especially if your wife is forcing you
so i think that probably explains
[Music]
how this happened if anyone is wondering
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated